edc is finally here with more than four
hundred thousand fans are heading over
to the las vegas motor speedway are you
going no but one of those fans is our
executive selena
she's a huge fan speaking of selena our
executive producers has been working has
been working to get you the biggest
names here in edm here's a wrap-up of
what fans can expect
it's kind of like the edm super bowl
it's a beautiful thing honestly a
witness and we're both very appreciative
of it
we show up and we vibe with each other
back and forth
[Music]
it's all about the experience you know
it's it's a place where you go
and you can never leave that place the
same person you just got you know you
can never leave the festival or the same
person that got in you can be free
[Music]
edc has always been kind of that
festival that i like
that i prepare the most for that i
you know get really nervous for like
it's one of the only festivals that i
really just am like so excited to play i
mean i'm excited to play all of them but
this one is just like it's followed me
throughout my career you can work on the
set
like forever but the truth is it's just
about what you bring to the show what
the energy that you
[Music]
bring it's a well-produced festival
amazing location one of the few
festivals that can go all night that
track
all the lights all the stages is just
special edc is truly special
you know when you're coming here it's
going to be a party it's going to be a
vibe there's going to be so many people
and people are going to be accepting of
what you're playing to
[Music]
being there is it's undescribable even
if you're new to the to the sound to the
music or you don't know you don't think
it's your cup of tea
being out there and feeling that many
people being
their best selves
being that happy that energetic
and then you layer on the production
and the art i recommend checking it out
because it might
turn that switch on in your mind
just nothing like being there you have
to check it out once in your life
hi